I love Tolkien he read him when I was in
junior high school he had a profound
effect on me he's the the father of all
modern fantasy we are working in the
shadow of the great mountain that is
Lord of the Rings but that being said
Tolkien did certain things that that are
different than what I would do and in
the hands of some of the Tolkien
imitators those things have become
cliches that I think have have
ultimately harm that genre and made it
make people think that it's a you know
entertainment for children or for
particularly slow adults and all this
stuff about the Dark Lord is rising in
the north and you know the good guys
have to get together to fight em guys
and handsome guys in white cloaks
fighting really ugly guys who dress all
in black you know the battle between
good and evil that's fine I battle
between good and evil is a universal
theme not only for fantasy but for any
fiction but my opinion has always been
that the battle between good and evil is
fought within the individual human heart
all of us have the capacity for good all
of us have the capacity for evil the
same people have the capacity for doing
that on different days you you read
about war heroes who save their whole
platoon and are incredibly brave and
then they go home and they beat up their
wives or they become an alcoholic or
they become a thief and things like that
how do you reconcile that well they're
human beings and human beings are
endlessly fascinating to me and the fact
that we we do have good and evil in us
that we can we can be angels where we
can be monsters and how do we make these
choices how do we go through life and
that's the stuff I love to to wrestle
with